French president Emmanuel macron wants
the wildfires in the Amazon rainforest
to be on the agenda this weekend's g7
meeting Brazilian president Jair bolson
ro authorized the military to join the
fight against the fires starting today
hundreds are being set in order to clear
the rainforest for agricultural use
deforestation has increased since bolson
ro took office last year he has in the
past described rainforest protection as
an obstacle to his country's economic
development our next guest has spent
more than a decade exploring the Amazon
naturalist Paul rosalie wrote about his
experiences in the jungle in his 2014
book mother of God and recently he got a
first-hand look at the fires burning
through the Amazon I'm not gonna be able
to stay here long to despise spreading
but everything behind me right now is
the forest that I've been working to
protect for the last 13 years it's
burning like this every day there are
literally millions of animals in this
forest that cannot escape right now and
if you think our planet can survive this
everyday in the Amazon you have another
thing coming and Paul Rosalee joins us
here in studio 57 good morning
good morning thanks for having thank you
for being here let's start with this
idea we hear why they want to have these
fires burning but there are more now yes
then we've seen in the past why because
we're the Amazon is a loop okay it's
it's producing the moisture that creates
all that rain that makes it a rain
forest and as we chop more of the rain
for that's been going on for decades
this is not an isolated issue right as
we chop more of the rainforest what
we're risking is reaching a tipping
point where that moisture system it
might be too dry to create the rain and
then you have a serious problem on your
hands because you're talking about the
entire Amazon sort of collapsing the
international community is really
pushing Brazil's president more I'm just
curious why does he see the Amazon not
as what it is the lungs of the earth and
instead an obstacle to economic
development well because the the
standing rainforest while it's producing
ecosystem services for all of us it's
not making money for him and so that may
be something that we need to change it's
not growing soybeans soybeans for Brazil
yeah and beef is 60% of Amazon
deforestation so it's really short-term
game versus health for everybody
and long-term health for the planet is
that supported there in Brazil that idea
his idea depends which party it depends
which party you're on it also it also he
no one really knows what's going on
because I just just this morning I saw a
video of him getting out of a car and he
goes the NGOs are doing it he's blaming
it on conservationists now and he feels
like he is a personal attack on him that
we're saying you need to protect the
Amazon rainforest but again this sort of
transcends political boundaries this
isn't something that one nation is to
deal with this is something I think the
entire planet depends right the question
is how you incentivize Brazil to
potentially change something the way
they're doing to help everyone else
because they're worried about helping
themselves right now absolutely well I
mean the thing is that you can all kinds
of Aid and incentives can be given to
Brazil but I mean we have to reimagine
our entire relationship with nature
because these problems are going to pop
up more and more everywhere everywhere
and there's fires raging in Indonesia
right now in the next few days it's
going to come out but then then we're
all going to forget about it and then
the rains going to come and then next
year it's going to get worse again and
every year if it gets worse at what
point are we just out of time so what
can the person at home do I mean there's
so many organizations right now that are
working doing good work to protect
rainforests to protect habitats and
let's not forget I mean really I'm here
as a representative for the animals
we're all talking about whether this is
good or good for us or not there are
animals in that rainforest that need
help that that's their only home and
they're people there too and there's 12
million people living in their community
exactly indigenous communities living
there and it's not going to help them if
their home is being destroyed
how often are loggers in the Amazon
replanting loggers would never be
replanting I mean people are trying to
replant but the thing is rainforests are
ancient ecosystem a thousand year old
trees complex ecology so really people
protecting what's already standing my
organization jungle keepers we work to
protect primary forest we forest that is
producing those rains that's coming down
and keeping the rainforest going but for
everybody at home like this is a moment
when like the global attention is
focused on the rainforest and it's like
now is the chance where we can actually
get leaders and policy makers to pay
attention to this good to have your poll
thank you very much for having me